if you're worried that the PlayStation
4's lifecycle is coming to an end you
can rest easy despite the upcoming
release of Sony's more powerful
PlayStation 4 codenamed neo this doesn't
mean that the ps4's life cycle will end
any earlier Shuhei Yoshida president of
Sony's worldwide studios said in an
interview well no ps4 is ps4 you know
the new high-end ps4 is still a ps4 so
the lifecycle is not going to be any
shorter it sounds like the neo in the
ps4 will complement each other the neo
will be the pricier and more high-end
console whereas the standard model will
be more affordable Yoshida's comments
match up with what playstation president
andrew house said this month when he
confirmed that a more powerful ps4 is in
development he said quote it is intended
to sit alongside and complement the
standard ps4 we will be selling both
versions throughout the lifecycle the
Neo currently doesn't have a release
date but a report said that it would
arrive this year there's no word yet on
a price but we'll be sure to let you
know as soon as we find out for more
news and all sorts of new console
goodness stay tuned to gamespot com
you